[موسيقى]
اذا الغيم تنهمر الحروف
فان لبست مقاليد المعاني مسطره تنوء بها
الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم باب فقال الدهر قد
جاز الوقوف
بحنوا الفتى يخبرنا عن فضل الفتى والنار
مخبره بفضل العنبر السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
البيانيه في القران الكريم قول الله تعالى
من يشفع شفاعه حسنه يكن له نصيب منها ومن
يشفع شفاعه سيئه يكن له كفل منها وكان
الله على كل شيء مقيتا
الكثل في اللغه هو النصيب والمساوي
ام النصيب فهو جزاء المطلق وليس شيئا
محددا في الايه استخدم الله تعالى كلمه
طفل عند ذكر السيئه يكن له كفل منها لان
السيئات تجزى بقدرها ولا يزاد عليها اما
الحسنه
وقد تكون عشرات اضعافا وقد تكون اكثر
اللهم انا نسالك زياده من كل خير
[موسيقى]
قال احدهم خرجت ليله من قريه لبعض شاني
فاذا انا باعمى على عاتقه جره وبيده سراج
فلم يزل حتى انتهى الى النهر وملا جرته
وعهد فقلت له يا هذا انت اعمى والليل
والنهار عندك سواء فما تصنع بالسراج قال
يا كثير الفضول حملته لاعمى القلب مثلك
يستضيء به لان لا يعثر في الظلمه فيقها
علي ويكسر جرتي
لعمرك ما الابصار وتنفع اهلها اذا لم يكن
للمبصرين بصعائره
[موسيقى]
الفضه معدن معروف يستعمل في الحلي والدواء
وفي الصناعه اسمه مشتق من الفعل فضه
بالشده او فضه بفك التضعيف ومن معانيه
بحسب لسان العرب فضت الشيء كسرته وفرقته
وقد سمي فضه لانفضاض اجزاءه اي تفرقها في
تراب معدنه قبل ان تصفى وتهذب وتسبك
الوليمه طعام العرس والاملاك وقيل هي كل
طعام صنع لعرس وغيره
والمترو تفيد الاجتماع لان العروسين
يجتمعان في العرس فلولمه تمام الشيء
واجتماعه
مازلنا حتى هذا اليوم نسمع كلمه القهوه
وعلمه
اسماؤها في بعض مناطق الجزيره العربيه
بمعنى القهوه جاهزه يقول لك تفضل القهوه
والمه بمعنى القهوه جاهزه
دليل على ان الاستخدام ما زال بنفس الدلال
القديمه وهي تمام الشيء
[موسيقى]
ادعي رجل النبوه في ايام المهدي فقدخل
عليه فقال له الى من بعثت قال ما تركتموني
اذهب الى من بعثت اليهم فاني بعثت بالغداء
وحبستموني بالعشي صباحك المهدي وخلا سبيلا
احيانا خفه الدم خلصت من المصائب
[موسيقى]
قال قيس بن الملوح يقولون كم تجري مدامع
عيني لها الدهر دمع واقف يتحدر وليس الذي
يجري من العين ماؤها
ولكنها نفس تدور
وقال ابن نباته المصري وان كنت مجنونا
بعشقك دائما فاني بنبل المقلتين مصاب تعبر
عن وجدي سرور
كانك يا خدي لهن كتابه
ويقول محدثكم في الشعر اختصر القراءه
مسرعا واذا قراتك اعشق التطويلا انت
اختصرتي جمال كل بثينه وانا احاول ان اكون
جميل
[موسيقى]
الفرق بين اتجاه واتجاه
تجاه او تجاه هي ظرف مكان وتعني ناحيه او
قباله نقول تقدم العدو تجاه المدينه ونقول
هذا واجبنا تجاه الاهل وفي ذلك قال النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم لعبد الله بن عباس رضي
الله عنهما احفظ الله تجده تجاهك اما
اتجاه فهي مصدر الفعل اتجه نقول اتجه
اتجاها وتعني ايضا الجهه او الناحيه نقول
سار القارب في الاتجاه الصحيح
[موسيقى]
يستعمل والناس قدام بمعنى امام فيقولون
جلس قدامي اي امامي والكلمه فصيحه وقد ورد
في جمهره اللغه كنت امامه اي قدامه
الدكه تستخدم في بعض كلام من الدارج
للدلاله على مكان مسطح يرتفع عن الارض
يتخذوا مجلسا وعاده ما يكون خارج البيت في
ايذاء الباب هذا الاستخدام صحيح وقد ورد
في لسان العرب الدكه بناء ان يصبح اعلى
يقول المثل حتى انت يا بروتس فما هي قصه
هذا المثل
المثل صار كلمه او عباره تستخدم بشكل شائع
جدا للتعبير عن الخيبه وقسوه الغدر من
المقربين الذين لا نتوقع منهم الاساءه اصل
هذا المثل يعود الى العصر الروماني مع
تمكن القائد الرومانيوس قيصر من الاتيان
بانتصارات وامجاد عظيمه لبلاده
ومع عودته الى روما تضاربت طموحاته
بالسيطره والتفرد مع مصالح اعضاء مجلس
الشيوخ الذين اخافتهم سطوت هذا القائد
الجديد التي كانت بلا حدود وكان ان اتفقوا
على التخلص منه علنا حتى يكون عبره
للحالمين الذين سياتون من بعده واتفقوا
على ان يضربوه بخناجرهم مجتمعين حتى يتفرق
دمه بينه
وهكذا كان في مجلس الشيوخ هاجموا عليها
واسخنوا فيه طعنا وهو يقاومهم وكانت
الطعنه الاخيره من خنجر الشاب الذي كان
يعتبره قيصر ابنا له هذا هو بروتس ابن
ماركس حيث يقال ان القيصر صاح في وقتها
حتى انت يا بروتس
الحادثه الحقيقيه وهذا مؤكد لكن الاقوال
المنقوله قد لا تكون كذلك هذه الاقوال
منقوله عن مسرحيه يوليوس قيصر
كما تعرفون طبق الافاق بكل اللغات وصار
تعبيرا عن ان الم الغدر قد يكون اقسى من
الالم الطعن
وقد قال الشاعر العربي قديما وظلم ذوي
القربى اشد مضاضه على المرء من واقع
الحسام المهندس
[موسيقى]
تباريح الشوق لوعته وتكاليفه
ونقول لعج الحب والشوق قلبه اي اضماه
واحرقه
ويقولون هاء الرجل الى المراه ان يشتاق
ويقولون نشره المراه اي شهقه من شوقها
وكان يغمى عليها
ويقولون دلها الشخص اي تحير وذهب عقله من
هم او عشق
قالوا في بعض العيوب عند الفرس
يقال فرس عضوض اذا عضت فارسها
ونفور اذا نفرت من من ازادها
وجموح اذا كانت تركب راسها لا يردها شيء
وجرور اذا كانت تجر الرسم وتمنع القيام
وحارون اذا كانت تتوقف في مشيها حتى لو
ضربت
وحبوص اذا كانت تميل عن الجهه التي يريدها
فارسها
وعثور اذا كانت كثيره العثار وقطوف اذا
كانت تمشي وثبا
وشبوه اذا كانت ترفع يديها وتقوم على
رجلها
[موسيقى]
سالتكم في تويتر عن اجمل العبارات الشكر
التي مرت عليكم في صفحات الايام والكتب
وفيما يستعرض معكم بعض ما وصلني من هذه
المشاركه
مشاركه من مالك يقول
تملك الحمد حتى ما لمفتخر في الحمد حاء
ولا ميم ولا دال
جميل يا مالك
هذه مشاركه من مدرس اسمه عرب يقول من
صفحات الايام وبعد ان انهيت درس اللغه
العربيه للصف الرابع وقفت احدى الطالبات
ونظرت الي بعينين
تطلب الاذن بالكلام ففعلت فقالت شكرا لك
استاذنا وصفقت بيديها تصفقت الاخريات كان
شكرها لي عذبا جميلا لانه خرج من قلب بريء
ليس هناك اجمل من براءه الاطفال
دكتور فيصل صديق البرنامج يقول الشكر افضل
ما حاولت ملتمسا به الزياده عند الله
والناس
يا سلام ابن سنان الخفاجي
ومشاركه من ابابيل تقول شكرا جميلا لك
اسعدني وجودك وجودك
حسابك سحابك
وردودك ورودك اكمل ولا خلاص لا خلاص شكرا
مشاركه من صوت الحق يقول قال داوود عليه
السلام يا رب كيف اشكرك وشكرا لك نعمه منك
علي فقال الله تعالى الان شكرتني يا داوود
اي حين اعترفت بالتقصير عن اداء شكر النعم
هذه مشاركه صوت الحق
مشاركه من ميرا تقول شكرت جميله
بدمعي
شكرتم جميل
مقياس الشعور
لاول مره قد ذاق جفني على ماذا دمع السرور
ومشاركه اخيرا من خالد يقول
فتبسم ضاحكا من قولها وقال ربي اوزعني ان
اشكر نعمتك التي انعمت علي وعلى والدي وان
اعمل صالحا ترضاه وادخلني برحمتك في عبادك
الصالحين الايه
اما انا فاذا سمحتم لي ان اشارك فاني قد
تذكرت بيتا لجرير يقول فيه
واثبت القوادم في جناحي الستم خير من ركب
المطايا واند العالمين
احدثكم عن كاتب وشاعرا ومحقق ومدافع شرس
عن الحضاره العربيه والاسلاميه
محمود ابن محمد شاكر بن احمد بن عبد
القادر من اسرته ابي علياء الحسينيه
ولد في الاسكندريه سنه 29
في القاهره مع انتقال والده اليها بعد
تعيينه وكيلا للجامع الازهر
الشهادتين الابتدائيه والثانويه وتملكه
بتعلم الانجليزيه والرياضيات وتخرج بشهاده
الثانويه العلميه في نفس الوقت كان متعمقا
في قراءه الادب العربي وقد حفظ ديوان
المتنبي كاملا وهو فتى وحضر دروس الادب
التي كان يلقيها الشيخ المرسى في جامع
السلطان برقوق
تملكه حب الادب فحاول الالتحاق بكليه
الاداب قسم اللغه العربيه لم يكن ذلك
متاحه نظرا الى شهادته العلميه تدخل
الاديب طه حسين لدى رئيس الجامعه المصريه
ليساعده في الالتحاق ولكن والمفارقه ان طه
حسين ذاته كان السبب في تخليه عن الدراسه
الجامعيه ايضا فقد اجتمع شاكر الشاب الى
محاضرات طه حسين على الشاعر الجاهلي التي
اشار فيها الى قضيه انتحال الشعر الجاهلي
فهاله ان يجرد استاذه امر القيس وزهير بن
ابي سلمى من اشعارهما
هذا الشعور بالغيظ انه وجد في اقوال طه
حسين اصل اصل مدويه لما قاله المستشرق
مارغوليس التي قرا عنها في مجله
الاستشراقيه
يقول في ذلك
تتابعت المحاضرات وكل يوم يزداد وضوح هذا
السطو العريان على مقاله مرجوليود ويزداد
في نفسي وضحوا الفرق بين فريقتي في
الاحساس بالشهر الجاهلي وبين هذه الطريقه
التي يسلكها الدكتور طه في التسليفها
بالشعر
صاحبنا تهيب اول الامر من مناقشه استاذه
لكنه لاحقا وقف يرد عليه بصراحه مباشره
وما لبس ان اعترته الخيبه فقرر ترك
الجامعه وهو في الثلاث الثانيه والانصراف
الى دراسه الادب بعيدا عن جدران الجامعه
بدا باعاده قراءه الشعر العربي كله او ما
وقع تحت يده منه ويقول قرات كل ما يقع تحت
يدي من كتب اسلافنا من تفسير لكتاب الله
الى علوم القران الكريم الى دواوين من
حديث رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم مع
الشروح الى ما تتفرع عليه من كتب العلماء
وعلماء الحديث وكتب الجرح والتعديل وكتب
اصول الفقه واصول الدين يقول وما شئت بعد
ذلك من ابواب العلم
في هذه الفتره نشرت بعض قصائده في مجلتي
الفتح والزهراء واتصل باعلام عصره من
امثال احمد تيمور احمد زكي باشا الرافعي
يصف هذه الفتره بقوله بدات احساسا مبهما
انها حياه ادبيه فاسده فلم اجد لنفسي
خلاصا الا ان ارفض متخوفا حذرا شيئا فشيئا
اكثر المناهج الادبيه والسياسيه
والاجتماعيه والدينيه
في الشعر يقول في قصيدته يا صفي يا رياح
انظري يا رياح ذا القبس الوهاج قدري
وغلفنا اقتدار
عاشت تحت الاطباق دهرا فدهرا يتلوى بثقلهن
بهاره صدع الصخره الململمه الكبرى واسرى
حتى لما فاستطار
وراى نوره فجن من الفرحه اعمى راى الظلام
لها
في عام
1936 نشر كتابه والاول المتنبي
تذاعصيته باسلوبه الجديد في مقاربه هذا
الشاعر العظيم
والاستنتاجاته غير المسبوقه وقد جاء بعد
ذلك كتاب طه حسين عن المتنبي فا اشتعلت
الخصومه مجددا حيث اعتبر محمود شاكر ان طه
حسين انتهج من هجه
وسطى على بعضه وهاجمه في سلسله مقالات
ثم اشتعلت لاحقا معركه بينه وبين لويس عوض
اثر نشر الاخير مجموعه مقالات هاجم فيها
المعري
لم تكن علاقه محمود شاكر بنظام الناصري
طيبه وقد سجن مرتين لمعارضته العالميه مع
ذلك بقي مواظب على مواقفه وانتاجه
وعلى رفعه الصوت ضد المستشرقين ومن يمالهم
برايه والذين يستهدفون مكونات ثقافه الامه
وحافظ على التعايش بما يجني من الكتب التي
يحققها من غير ان يقبل قرشا عن مقالاته
التي ينشرها
من مؤلفاته طبعا المتنبي اباطيل واسمار
نمط صعب ونمط مخيف مداخل اعجاز القران وله
الكثير وغيرها من المؤلفات في الشعر القوس
العذراء اوصفي يا رياح وقصائد اخرى
وقد حقق العديد من كتب التراث منها فضل
العطاء على العسر لابي هلال العسكريه
طبقات فحول الشعراء لمحمد بن سلام الجمهحي
تفسير الطبري دلائل الاعجاز واسرار البلاغ
لعبد القادر الجرجاني
محمود شاكر مالا جائزه الدوله التقديريه
في الادب في عام
1981 وجائزه الملك فيصل في الادب العربي
واختيار عضوا في مجمع اللغه العربيه بدمشق
ثم في القاهره
رحل ابو فهر شيخ العربيه في عام
تاركا وراءه وارثا عظيما يتجدد مع كل صباح
يفكر فيه العرب
بثقافتهم العربيه
وارتباطها بحضارتهم العريقه
[موسيقى]
بعض الناس يعتقد ان
المكان التي يكنها لك في صدره تعتمد على
مدى القرب والبعد فاذا كنت طويل الغياب او
كثير الغياب
تنخفض هذه المكانه واذا كنت كثيرا الحضور
تبقى المكانه حاضره
وانا على مذهب غير هذا
انا
ارى ان مكانه الصديق عند صديقه والحبيب
عند حبيبه لا ينبغي لها ان تكون مشروطا
لذلك اقول لكم
حب الاحبه راسخ في اضلعي صيانه عندي
باعدوا او قربوا
يلقى الفتى وطنا بوجه صديقه حتى ولو ان
الفتاه متغرب السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]